tonight is the season finale of Grey's
Anatomy the show decided to end season
16 early due to the coronavirus shutdown
but the hit ABC drama still has a reason
to celebrate the cast is sharing some
set secrets even diehards don't know I
[Music]
haven't watched any of them to be honest
we're shooting it so much that last
thing I want to do is actually launch
the show Ellen doesn't watch great
that's one secret one more the show was
originally going to be called surgeons
McDreamy was supposed to have a teenage
daughter from his first marriage in
Jackson was only slated to beyond for
two episodes producers liked him so much
he stay what's your name
Jackson Avery I mangled my audition and
asked for a redo just don't blow it just
don't blow it they're gonna realize I
made a mistake after Justin chambers
shocking exit last month only three
original cast members remain tonight
season finale is titled put on a happy
face and from the looks of it things are
gonna get intense are you here to help
it's Alzheimer's Meredith I do not
believe that it is we have to end with
this episode because it was the ones
that we finish with it's gonna totally
work as finale and I think again is
quintessential grace you will be
laughing and crying simultaneously yeah
TV's longest-running medical show still
brings all the drummond so we wanted to
know what are some of the cast's best of
gray's moments me and nurse Ilan the
on-call room Derek walked in on us
Oh what is the most iconic Grey's
Anatomy quote that is your favorite
Cristina Yang's line to Meredith he is
not the son you are he's not the son
you are the hell of a line it's a
beautiful day to save save lives
it's beautiful day to save class or when
Sandra Oh says somebody's sedate me
that's probably the best Grey's Anatomy
moment of all time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]